esta semana comenzó la temporada de
grandes ligas para analizar este inicio
de campaña conectamos con Enrique rojas
reportero senior de la cadena y ESPN que
nos atiende desde Orlando Florida
Enrique Muchas gracias por estar con
nosotros qué podemos concluir hasta
ahora de la nueva reglamentación que se
empezó a aplicar está funcionando a la
hora de agilizar el juego hemos visto
mucha discrepancia sobre todo a la hora
de los castigos cuando se trata del
tiempo
Saludos lo primero es que hay que
recordar que la temporada de grandes
ligas es la más larga de cualquier
calendario de cualquier liga profesional
del planeta tierra Por lo tanto cuatro
días No son exactamente la medida
para evaluar Cómo van las reglas pero lo
que tenemos son cuatro días y hasta
ahora los juegos han terminado realmente
a un ritmo de lo que se buscaba la
ofensiva se ha mantenido se ha eliminado
el tiempo basura que se agregaba a los
juegos te podría decir que cuarenta
violaciones que es lo que hemos tenido
en los primeros 100 juegos es una media
realmente extraordinaria
la primera semana del reglamento hay que
tomar en cuenta que el reloj se usa
entre picheo y picheo en un juego normal
hay cerca de 300 lanzamientos 100 juegos
serían tres mil lanzamientos y solamente
van cuarenta violaciones es un asunto de
adaptarse pero yo creo que lo están
haciendo extraordinariamente rápido los
jugadores y los árbitros todo esto
pensando en el espectáculo vamos a
cambiar de tema vamos a alejarnos de las
reglas Quiero preguntarle ahora Enrique
Por quiénes son para ustedes los equipos
a tener en cuenta a la hora de pelear
por el Campeonato este año quien puede
pelear por los astros por ese título que
igualmente los astros están en capacidad
de defender
Eso es así cuando tú vas a hablar del
campeón de la temporada actual tiene que
pensar en el último campeón qué tal su
nómina si se mantuvo casi igual bueno se
fue José Abreu el cubano que se marchó
Perdón se fue Yuli gurriel pero vino
José Abreu desde los medias blancas de
Chicago O sea que se pusieron más fuerte
en ese sentido Aunque perdieron a Justin
Lander el caballo
ganador de múltiples premios que se fue
a los Mex de Nueva York en sentido
general tienen un equipazo debe ganar la
división oeste debe competir hasta las
últimas instancias para representar la
liga en la serie mundial Eso sí en la
Liga Nacional hay varios equipos que
pueden darle la pelea a cualquiera otra
vez los Dodgers de Los Ángeles que no es
una novedad Los Bravos de Atlanta que
ganaron hace dos años los de Filadelfia
vienen de ser barridos en el fin de
semana por Texas pero es un equipo que
debe pelear hasta el último tramo de la
temporada y están los reforzados padres
de San Diego
tienen de regreso a Fernando tatis para
el 20 de abril tienen a Juan Soto por
toda una temporada junto con Sander
buckers a quien firmaron en la agencia
libre luego de que no pudo llegar a un
acuerdo con los medias rojas de Boston
es un equipazo que si no logra meterse
por lo menos a la final de Liga sería un
fracaso rotundo el de los padres de San
Diego y por supuesto los Mex de Nueva
York un equipo que ganó ciento un juegos
el año pasado pero se quedó corto de
conseguir lo grande agregó a berlander
tiene nuevas aspiraciones berlander está
en lista de lesionados pero será por
poco tiempo Houston Yankees también
Atlanta Dodgers
los principales sospechosos para
levantar la corona los mets increíble la
inversión económica que he tenido este
equipo para esta campaña precisamente
pensando en nuestra audiencia
latinoamericana ya usted nos ha
adelantado algunos nombres Qué figuras
de la región de América Latina podemos
destacar para esta campaña
el 30% de los peloteros de grandes ligas
son extranjeros y ese porcentaje es
abrumadamente latinoamericano entonces
tú piensas Ronald Acuña Juniors está de
regreso saludable es un pelotero que te
podría hacer un cuarenta cuarenta y
estar en la conversación del más valioso
Juan Soto y Manny Machado la súper
pareja Dominicana de los padres de San
Diego va a estar en la conversación pero
también Sanders quien tendrá un rol
protagónico con un equipo champeonable
Miguel Cabrera está retirándose
Posiblemente no va a estar compitiendo
por premios especiales de la temporada
pero qué tal seguir acumulando
estadísticas ya tiene más de tres mil
hits Ya tiene más de 500 horrores más de
600 dobles pero es un tipo que cada vez
que pega un imparable tuvo un escalón en
la lista de todos los tiempos y vamos a
ver qué tal doble tigre pone esa vara
rumbo a su próxima parada luego de esta
temporada con Detroit que será en cinco
años El Salón de la Fama de cooperstown